Mình sẽ hảm ảm ảy thằng hai, hảm ảm ảnh thúc tổn rồi tờ rất lời một quan trức các cạo i ra
cho biết, Té Ràn sẽ sản cần nhắc các những bộ mời trong đảng
hả nhân bởi vì điều kiện Washington rất bỏ trình phát và không giận quyền làm giấu
ra như về một địch, phà bình của Té Ràn. Cú thể thông ơn tiến,
Té Ràn có thể xuất khẩu một nửa lượng udan yu m làm giấu ở mất cao ra nước ngoài
phà lóng phẩm cẩn lại và tham gia một cơ trẻ làm giấu khu vực.
Được lại, Té Ràn yu cầu một lộ trình giữa bỏ trình phát hợp li, dựa trên lợi xong phương,
tuy nhiên hiện Iran và Mỹ rất đồng về phạm vi và trình tự nửa lòng các bạn phát trình phát.
Ngồi chừng, à bác, róc trí dự kiến đặc đặc phải viên Mỹ Street with Thorc,
tại Junior Vào trong tần này trong khi tổn rồi đồng của gun on Trump,
vẫn đang nỗ lực gời sự áp là Iran khi đẹn gọt cả năng tên hành không biết hạm chế,
nhiều không đặt được một thỏe thật trong hơn mùi ngày nữa.
Sông sông bơi tên chính đả phạm về Mỹ, một lần sống biểu tình mới đang mang nhà xuất hiện tại Iran,
khi sing viên tại một số trường đại học, tên Ràn và Mà Sát đã biểu tên yếu sáng ngày thứ 2 liên tiếp.
Truy nhiên, nhá nước Iran phát hình hạnh cho thấy các nhóm bị mũ tảng là giả vài anh sing viên,
nêm đá mừng người ủng hộ chi vụ trong khi một số tổ chức quan sát cho biết,
được lượng anh đến đã các thiệp và cóng người bị thương.